happy Friday guys let's run through some
games that are heavy on fun and light on
your wallet first up a game you might
have played on the xbox 360 is now on PC
happy wars is a team-based third person
action game that shoves the cute in your
face and takes no prisoners I mean
really can't because your goal is to
kill them you'll leave your castle
capture towers in route to the enemy
castle and then destroy that said enemy
castle play as three character classes
you got your adorable warrior your
darling cleric or the murderous mage the
warrior is resilient and deals a lot of
melee damage and the mage deals ranged
damage and can buff allies weapons you
start each match with an in-game level
of one and then you unlock additional
skills as you go mobis tile kill to your
little hearts content it's free on steam
now next up bill killem steps in to
satisfy your run and gun needs on iPhone
and iPad mr. killem is here to kick ass
and collect time because you're running
out each game starts with 25 seconds on
the clock and a standard Glock blast
aliens in your way to score points and
collect coins to use in-game to purchase
upgrades and extra lives when you
inevitably touch one of the flying alien
things the real fun comes from all the
guns there's so many different types of
shootie things like the shotgun and the
machine gun laser gun and the
flamethrower of course the rocket
launcher looks like red crayon and
they're all accompanied by awesome music
and it can be yours a 399 this week and
this week only EA is offering origin
users a free copy of battlefield 3
on the house and it's only free until
june third the six co-op missions and
compelling multiplayer is more than
enough to make you want this amazing
combat shooter and you get until 10 a.m.
pacific time on jun 3rd to claim your
free be once you download it's yours to
keep for life so get on down origin
today and grab yourself a copy i got
and finally outsmart your opponents in
tactical turn-based combat with arena
build a team of champions to punch and
shoot enemies in this addictive strategy
game and game spots giving you starter
pack keys that let you choose between a
free ships or a champion just go to
gamespot com / arena give away to claim
yours a total of four free games to get
your weekend started just right start
playing and enjoy your weekends